Does your kid have a weird obsession?
Mine does, and it's the Titanic.
That being said,
I grabbed this Titanic brick building set that I found on TikTok Shop.
This set seems to be inspired by the movie
and even comes with Jack and rose.
My son added this little bit right here with the floating door.
Inside is not to scale, but it does have some cool feature.
It has them staircase and Rose's apartment
and also has the safe in the cargo area in the back.
This is also where the light switches.
So it does have a light kit.
And of course, you couldn't be without the heart of the ocean.
Even though none of this is the scout,
it's still kind of fun to have the stuff to put inside
and it's kind of a playable piece.
My son did need help with this.
He is 7 years old and it was a complicated piece,
so a great set to bond over with a parent.
This set was so much fun,
and it's gonna be a great display piece with the light kit.
This comes with free shipping, so grab yours now on TikTok Shop.
You will not regret it.